[Musik]
wir befinden uns hier mit der charta
präsenz einheit vom aufstellungsort
alberto león 71 zwar ring und diese
woche steht bei unserem programm der
kampf im mobilen umfeld wir fokussieren
uns vor allem auf die geschäftstüchtigen
dass ein zu schützen
das einzelschützen in weiterer folge des
drucks und der gruppe als basis sowie
der infanterist die egger gruppe ihre
techniker arbeiten um dann als
endprodukt einmal dieser woche zu lassen
okay diese elemente nehmen wir für
unsere aufgabe und bauen auf dieses auf
das haben dinge wie das vorgänger einer
gruppe in einem straßenzug zu überwinden
von kreuzungen jeder ort es geht darum
ein trinkt punkte in gebäude und objekte
zu finden und anzunehmen mit und ohne
kampf gipfeln das ganze im sogenannten
zielorientierten vorgehen wo wir dann
versuchen möglichst unerkannt schnell
den dementsprechenden die richtigen
gebäudeteilen das richtige objekt der
richtige rahmen für uns zu gewinnen und
den eigentlichen auftrag nämlich dass
bei drei mal bin ich der oder ähnliches
zu gewährleisten
[Musik]
derzeit bringt mit sich dass die moderne
konflikte szenarien sehr starken umfeld
gemischt global stattfinden und
zwangsläufig ist die
informationsgewinnung mit der aufklärung
inklusive sensorik ganz genauso in
dieses diesem raum wenn man so will
getränkter jetzt haben wir schon einige
schritte weiter was die technik wenn man
mal drinnen ist betrifft die db stelle
aus dem opernhaus
aber gott mobile ein konflikt den
kommunen umfeld gibt es ganz viele
variablen bis ich da hineinkommt und da
müssen wir weiter ansetzen um mit der
zeit zu gehen und vor allem mehr
kompatibel zu sein mit den vertreten